to Heinz I serve is the government
preparing for a second referendum no a
second referendum would be would be
divisive we had we've had the people's
vote we had the referendum and now we've
got to get on with we've got to get on
with implementing it and any idea
they're having a second second
referendum now would sort of break
through an impasse I just think is wrong
it might postpone the impasse but then
it would extend it so what we need to do
is get on with this the prime minister's
been in Brussels been talking to the
different European leaders to help
secure those extra reassurances that
colleagues understandably are looking
for on the back stop but then we have to
we have to get together again and we
have to we have to support a balanced
deal which gives us a good breaks it for
Britain you talked about Teresa Mays
negotiation but let's get real it's not
exactly been going to plan has it I mean
it doesn't look as if she's going to be
getting any of the kind of assurances
that she promised MPs before that vote
of confidence so you must have a plan B
surely is a second referendum something
that is being discussed at cabinet well
I think that what we saw in Brussels
this week Thursday Friday I think was it
was an important start but it's not the
it's not the end of the process by any
means and the PM will carry on those
discussions over the Christmas period
and then you know we'll come back in in
January but you know we talk about a
plan B there are about half a dozen
different options sort of going around
and all of them has their own strong
supporters but none of them has a
majority in favour you know whether you
talk about Norway or Canada or second
referendum or leaving without a deal or
whatever it may be and in the end what
we need is a balanced deal something
that's you know can appeal to obviously
- to those who voted to leave but also
appeal to those who voted remain it's
got to be a deal for the whole country a
balanced deal and the essence of what
the prime minister is negotiated does he
does exactly that you know it gets us
out of free movement get us out of the
common agricultural policy but means we
can strike trade deals and keeps a close
relationship economically and in other
ways with Europe and you know before the
referendum if you'd offered that deal
both many you know leaders and many
remain errs they would have bitten your
hand off it's a good deal a very
impassioned defense her the prime
ministers to the question was whether a
second
random has been discussed a cabinet
though has it no we know our government
policy is I mean couldn't be clearer we
are here to to act on the will of the
British people
no we are here to act on the will of the
British people clearly expressed in the
referendum but you know to do so in a
way which takes a balanced approach and
is good for people's jobs and
livelihoods and that's absolutely what
the Prime Minister and the cabinet are
focused on in one way of breaking the
deadlock because it does feel as if
we're in a bit of a gridlock here with
you know the EU not moving conservatives
backing the prime minister to stay on as
leader but not saying they're going to
change their minds at the boats is one
way of breaking that deadlock putting a
series of votes to the House of Commons
try and work out what there could be a
majority fall well I what we need I mean
is you sort of alluded to as people need
to get beyond you know everybody's idea
of what's my first choice because there
isn't a majority for any of those first
choices instead what you need is a
balanced kind of approach and when you
go from you know when you pick apart
your own first choice to start then
we'll walk out how would it work
something that would appeal more broadly
that balances all these different
objects and some of our different
objectives are you know there is a
certain conflict between them and when
you go through that process you get to
something very close to the deal that
the Prime Minister has put forward so
you know we have to remember all that we
have in common what the what the
essential objective is that we're trying
to do here to make sure we honor the
result of the referendum but do so in a
way which is economically it is
economically beneficial I think over the
Christmas be know it's a time when we do
think about all that we have in common
and we think about our togetherness and
we think about the future this will be a
good time I hope for everybody to
reflect on that so that we can so that
we can all come together in support of a
good balanced deal and at the same time
there Christmas is also gonna be meaning
that a time for reflection as you say
but also the clock ticking brexit
getting close the possibility of no deal
are increasing as well if we move to
full no deal planning can you guarantee
that money won't be diverted from the
education budget in order to
it's a direct question so I'd appreciate
a direct answer yeah I'll give you a
very direct answer education is an
absolutely top priority of the
government that's why it was one of the
two domestic budgets another five
sixteenth school budget was one of the
two domestic budgets that's been
protected since 2010 and we will
absolutely be protecting that on an
ongoing basis that's not to say by the
way that No Deal isn't a serious is a
very serious thing and it's something we
absolutely need to we need to avoid but
but no education remain absolutely a top
priority come what may now tourism a has
earned some praise for keeping going in
the face of some pretty stiff opposition
but I just wonder at what point it looks
like she's sticking her fingers in her
ears because after having to delay the
vote no she said she would listen after
having the confidence motion in her
leadership 117 of her own MPs voted
against her she said she would listen
and yet I can't really detect any sign
of her actually changing course in any
meaningful way
have I missed it the Prime Minister has
been listening and you know this has
been it's been a very long process I
mean going through all these
negotiations and all at all stages the
Prime Minister has been listening to two
colleagues in Parliament of course two
people more broadly as well and that
helps to inform the negotiations but at
the end of the day there are some
conflicting objectives not everybody
thinks the same thing and so you know in
listening you're listening to different
groups and you have to come up with a
balanced approach which works for you
know which works for our country works
for all the people in our country
whichever way they voted in the in the
referendum you know think about the
interests of fishermen think about the
interests of farmers you've got to think
about the automotive industry and those
just-in-time
supply lines you've got to think about
you know the key things that people
voted on in that referendum are ending
free movement and so you end up with a
balanced deal much like the one that she
has she as she has done but there are
also these concerns understanding about
the backstop and that's why she's
expending all this time and energy
working again with the other European
leaders to secure additional
reassurances on that
okay balanced deal I've definitely got
that memo so I think we can move on from
the
and steel and we had the conference
motion in the prime minister at that
time the Conservative Party decided to
restore the whip to two MPs who had been
suspended one of them is still under
investigation by police for allegations
of sexual offences something that he
denies the other was this was resigned
after sending hundreds of explicit
messages to two women in his
constituency including I can't wait to
beat her can she take a beating
are you proud that the whip was restored
to those two men well in those two cases
we nose to colleagues I mean were
elected as Conservative MPs and they're
there to represent their constituents
and so I think it is right that in the
in the election for you know the the
confidence votes that there was that I
think it's right that they should have
been able to be part of that votes as
their constituents as their constituents
would would expect
okay now I'm keen to talk about your
brief we haven't got too long left on
the interview sadly and you are
announcing more money for special needs
there in school so just explain to Matt
to us what you're hoping to do and is
this new money yes so there have been
pressures significant pressures on local
authorities budgets what's called
high-needs which covers special
educational needs and disabilities and
some other areas as well there's been
more money actually been going into
high-needs over the last few years and
particularly since we brought in in 2014
and the children families at these new
education health and care plans and so
today we're announcing additional
revenue Manticore quarter of a million
pounds over two years to help to ease
some of those funding pressures on the
on the revenue side but also some
capital money to to spend on improve
facilities and equipment things like you
know sensory rooms to expand sdn units
in mainstream schools things like that
and also looking to to be able to
provide more places in special schools
where that's the right thing for that
for that child a number of other reforms
as well around training more educational
psychologists and making sure that we've
got the right training in place for
teachers so that all schools are best
equipped to be able to help and support
children special educational needs now
of course we all know about the big
budget pressures on schools so is it new
money and will it be ring-fenced so it
is it is money that goes specifically to
the height what's called the high needs
block in local authorities and they they
allocates money for four different
different purposes within special needs
you ask where the money comes from no
other budget is cut in order to in order
to be able to do this it's money that's
come from the when we adjust our
projections during the course thing
which happens every year
in terms of the number of pupils in
school the characteristics of different
pupils with the money that's been
available from that reprojection it was
my top priority to be able to put
additional resourcing towards it salt I
need special educational needs so that
that's what we've done
so not new money then from the Treasury
in within the existing schools budget
it's it's from existing depart for
education budgets but no other program
has been cut in order to in order to be
able to do this okay and I'm keen to
Oishi as well about whether there is a
wider issue in schools because of the
you know one-size-fits-all education
policy I mean we're talking about
children with high needs you know we
know that there's new mental health
pressures on our young people do you
think in the past there's been too much
of a focus on having all children no
matter what their personalities no
matter what their needs are focused on a
very academic curriculum where you're
expected to be sitting behind a desk for
all these hours a day right up to the
age of 18 is that failing our young
people well we have a we have a very
very good curriculum with with balance
in it and studying a wide variety of
subjects like by the way schools in
other countries as well there is special
provision rightly for children with
special needs and in some cases it's
right for those tuned to be in special
schools they're actually in very many
cases right for them to be in in
mainstream schools but you know I want
to see a broad and balanced curriculum
with children being able to try
different subjects trying different
things and onto the balance with sport
and extracurricular activities and so on
that and that's absolutely what I'll
continue to strive to do so is that been
too much of a focus on exams do you
think
exams are important I mean the report
for lots of different reasons I mean
what one of them one of the things is
you know it's it's a unique way of being
able to set out what you've learned to
show what you can do and and and that
kind of what comes with exams there is
some pressure that comes from but in
some ways that's rather like what
happens later in life and so in some
ways it's a good way to prepare you for
later life but it's not only about exams
you know what we all want for our
children is a broad and balanced
education we want them to discover the
joy of learning to be able later in life
to to come back to great literature in
history that they've discovered and we
also want them to discover other talents
that they have in practical things and
in the arts and music and so on and I
think it's really important that
throughout our education system there is
absolutely that breath and we recognize
that education yes it's about leaving
with GCSEs but it's also about
everything else about the development of
character the development of self and
you also mentioned mental health
pressures earlier we also have a greater
focus these days and some of the
pressures on kids these days that just
weren't around when we were where we
were children things like from the
internet and social media and stuff and
yes we do need him to make sure we have
enhanced support for that too